Continue working on your project or open the file named to-materials if you need to catch up.
Essentially, this file starts with the one from the last video left off.
Here, we'll use ready-made PBR materials from the Materials library to replace incoming materials from the DCC app, in this case Revit.
The process is simple. You can first sample a material using the Material Picker, such as the one on the curved walls.
Once the material is displayed on the right, you can make adjustments to it.
Better yet, you can replace it altogether with a better one from the Material library.
For that, you can go to the Materials subsection in the Asset library and choose a category such as Concrete.
You can hover over thumbnails to get a better representation of materials.
When you decide on a material, you can drag and drop it on an object in the viewport, or on the existing material in the right panel.
This replaces the old material with the new.
Right off the bat, you'll notice a UV problem. This happens sometimes with DCC apps that use a different unit system than Twinmotion.
Here, we'll need to adjust the UV Scale or Tiling to make this work.
Adjust the scale slider and note that it caps at 10.
If you need to go beyond that number, you can simply type in a value, in this case 20.
You can edit other values as well. For example, you can make the color a bit lighter by increasing the luminosity to about 80%.
Let's try another one. Let's apply the Polished Concrete 2 material to the cafe floor.
And notice how it also applies to the main building floor.
These two objects initially share the same incoming material from Revit, and therefore are both affected by the new material.
We still need to bring about a few edits, but first let's also apply that same material to the walls of the bar within the theater area.
You can do this from the displayed material on the right panel.
Now you can adjust the scale. I'll set mine at around 10.
Let's keep going. This time, we'll step back and go to the Ground category.
Under Manmade, use an Asphalt material, such as Asphalt 4, to apply onto the roof of the cafe.
Again, it replaces all surfaces sharing the original incoming material from Revit.
And again, it requires adjusting the UV Scale a bit. A value of 10 should do.
The Asphalt is a bit too clean. Sometimes it pays off to dirty it up a little bit.
All you need is to increase the amount of grunge. I'll set mine to about 35 or 40%.
This technique also breaks the monotony of UV tiling.
Let's do a few more around the theater area.
Perhaps apply a Wave Cobblestone material to the walking pathways.
And adjusting scale and grunge like earlier.
You can also add a Soft Concrete material for the stands, and possibly the front steps.
If you've already used the material and adjusted it, and then decide to use it again on a different object,
such as the wall material to replicate onto the stage for example,
then you can simply sample it first, and then drag it from the Properties panel onto the stage.
In this case, all adjustments to UVs and color and the likes are also retained.
Take a moment to experiment and add materials to the scene.
Try a glass material on the curtain wall, or a metal material on the mullions.
Keep in mind you can tint any material that you use in the scene.
Consider applying the same metal to other objects such as ramps, handrails, and planters maybe.
Try a wood material on the sides of the planters, or some grass where appropriate.
Experiment on your own in other areas of the project as well.
So far, material substitution has been going well, but there are situations that can catch you off guard.
Consider this area on the cafe floor.
It has the same Asphalt material as the roof.
If you try to change that by assigning another material to that patch only, say a Cobblestone material of some sort,
it will replace the Asphalt material anywhere else in the scene.
That's the nature of the Material Substitution tool.
Press Ctrl-Z to undo the last step.
You can prevent that from happening by switching the Replace Material Mode to Apply to Object.
Try it again and see that the cobblestones are only applied to that patch of ground.
Similar problems may appear when dealing with instances.
Look at the curtain wall panels on the main building.
Even though it just set the Material Mode to Apply to Object, note what happens when you apply a material to one of these panels on the main façade.
You'll notice that the materials apply to many of them simultaneously.
That's because even though these panels are separate entities, they are all based on the same Revit family.
This means they get imported as instances and therefore are treated the same way within Twinmotion.
To apply different materials to them, you need first to break the instancing.
Select all the non-glass panels on the main façade with the help of the Ctrl key.
Right-click on one of them in the scene graph and choose Break Instance.
From this point on, you can apply different materials to the different panels.
One final note to point out.
Beware of your UV coordinates between Twinmotion, OpenStreetMaps and your DCC app.
You've already noticed that in most cases, scaling factors would necessarily apply to work well with Revit geometry.
But if you were to sample one of those materials, such as the lawn material you used earlier for example,
and then try to apply it on a non-Revit object such as the green areas of the urban surroundings, the same settings would not work.
That's a discrepancy with the UV coordinates.
When that happens, you can try to reapply UV coordinates from the main toolbar, overwriting the object's UVs.
You'd need to reapply the material and then adjust its parameters globally.
This is starting to shape up.
In the next video, you'll experiment with other asset types that the Asset Library has to offer.